Hi and welcome back to another
VC libraries Open code review.
Today we'll be looking at a PR from Nicole
called Re-enable ASan string annotations.
This is PR #3164, so the background here
is that MSVC is working hard on adding
support for the address sanitizer that was
originally implemented in clang LLVM.
So we're taking their open source code
base and applying that to MSVC, and then,
additionally, our containers,
in particular the most popular
contiguous containers,
std::string and std::vector do something
that is a little bit unusual compared
to how users directly allocate memory.
With a string or a vector,
the container will allocate a big
block of memory all at once, and then
construct within it either characters
or elements, and as more elements
are pushed back or and placed
into the container,
um, the originally allocated
but not yet consumed memory is
used to store those elements,
and it's only when the container runs out of
unused capacity that it needs to reallocate.
And both string and vector use what's
known as a geometric reallocation policy.
Well, they'll,
where they'll allocate some multiple of
their capacity whenever they need to grow.
This is somewhat counterintuitive, but
it means that pushing back into them
results in amortized constant time,
which you would not get if
you had a naive policy of:
“oh, let's just allocate like plus
10 elements or something”,
which other libraries have had,
but the STL has never suffered from.
So the fact that for string and vector
the allocated memory is different from
the memory that actually holds elements,
or that the capacity in general
can be larger than the size,
um, poses challenges for ASan.
For address sanitizer,
we would like out of bounds accesses
to be detected if pointers or whatever
are being dereferenced into memory
that does not actually hold elements.
So just because it's been allocated,
if it's in that unused capacity
between the end of the container
size and the end of the container's
actual allocated capacity,
we would like that range to
be considered invalid.
Merely looking at what allocations the
program is performing would
not be sufficient to do that.
So that's where these annotations
come into play.
There are special commands that you can
give to the address sanitizer machinery –
and Nicole,
please jump in to correct me if I'm
characterizing this incorrectly –
there are these commands that
you can give to ASan that say:
“OK, I have allocated some memory,
but even though that memory
has been allocated,
I would like you to consider
it bogus for the time being”.
And these are…
these are what are referred
to as annotations.
So we've applied those to
both string and vector,
but then we discovered problems
with the string annotation.
String is an unusual container
because – unlike vector – it has
Small String Optimization where
strings that are below um 16 narrow
characters can be stored directly
within the string itself,
that never happens for a vector.
And additionally string has interesting
alignment properties compared to vector.
It does some unusual math there.
So we discovered some pretty
severe problems with the ASan string
annotations and had to disable
them before shipping so that it
wouldn't go break users who were
enabling address sanitizer.
So that has been the status quo for a while.
Nicole has now done the intensive
investigation needed to restore these
annotations and get them correct.
So that's what we'll be reviewing today.
So that is the background.
Let me take a look at the files
that are being changed here.
And Alt Click to minimize everything.
OK, so we have got changes to the ASan tests,
the existing tests,
we're not adding any new tests.
And then we've got product code changes
and we've got a new header being added,
an internal header stl/inc/__msvc_sanitizer_annotate_container
So the presence of a new header means that
we need to follow a checklist. In the STL
we are very fond of using checklists for
any complicated processes that we have to
do so that we don't forget important steps.
Um, if it's useful when flying a plane,
it's useful when making changes in the STL.
So here is our wiki page.
I fondly refer to this as “hack
these files” because that was the
name of our internal SharePoint
document before we made this public.
Now it's called, less excitingly,
files to edit when adding or removing files.
Ideally this would all be automated.
In practice we just need to make manual
edits to a bunch of different places.
The most annoying part is actually automated.
That's the part that Amy took care
of in the MSVC internal repo,
this LKG thing.
So there's just a script you need to
run there, but for everything else
it needs to be essentially manual.
So many possible things to forget there.
I will be comparing against those.
Let me split these. Um.
Wow, that split is not great.
Can I make that flow into a single line?
Yes, I can. OK.
So, new header.
I'll take a look at the new header.
Um, let's first go through.
This is divided into 3 sections,
edits in the GitHub repository,
MSVC internal, and then VS.
The VS IDE needs to be told when we're
adding new extensionless headers,
like the upcoming <print> header.
This is not an extensionless header
because it's internal and nonstandard.
It ends with hpp,
so that's not applicable.
So on the GitHub side,
new header means we should edit CMakeLists,
because we need to tell the
build system to copy these things.
So here it is. Uh, we've got.
I'm virtually certain this will work
because if this were misspelled,
it would not work at all.
Here we go.
Amy has commented that yes,
there is a needed setup change.
Yep, that is absolutely correct.
That's called out in the document here.
It's below.
So we've got the new header being added here.
It's in sorted order.
sa comes before sy, perfect,
and that's the only edit.
There's a few files where we need
to make two edits.
This is not one of them, so that's good.
Um, Next up,
there's a file in our legacy
MS Build directory,
and this is not a source file.
It's not separately compiled,
so this isn't applicable.
Um,
so next is if you add a public
header that is intended to be
directly consumed by users,
we need to put it in this test helper.
But this is an internal header,
it's not intended for users.
Onward header-units.json. This is
used for the C++20 header units feature.
When adding headers, regardless of
their whether they're public or private,
they should be eligible to be automatically
translated with a compiler option
from includes to header unit imports.
So we do need to edit header-units.json,
and here it's being listed again,
it is in sorted order.
That search is not picking it up
because I expanded that.
Yep, that's great.
OK, there will also be needed edits,
internal needed edits internally because
there is a compiler test for hitter units.
OK then, that's in the section below.
Here we're only reviewing the
changes for the GitHub repo.
OK, this is not a standard public header,
so no impact on the named module.
It's not a public header,
so we don't need to test whether
it can be included alone, and
not a standard public header.
OK, so checklist is good for the GitHub repo.
We will have to do additional
validation for the MSVC internal
repo when we mirror this over.
OK, so I'm gonna go ahead and close that.
Uh, let's take a look briefly
at what code is being extracted.
Nicole mentioned that to avoid
duplication between vector and string,
she's lifting code out into
this new internal header.
That's why we've got it here.
So I'm going to briefly scan to see OK,
some of this alternate name stuff
and then actual changes to string.
OK, and then vector.
Again,
the stuff that turns on the annotation,
more of that alternate name stuff.
Yeah, that code is either, it's,
I think, not quite identical,
but it's extremely similar,
just sort of exchanging vector
and string or swapping,
swapping them out, replacing them.
So OK, I believe that's what's being unified.
So now let's take a look at the new header.
OK,
so when adding a new header,
I like to look at an existing
header precedent,
because here we don't exactly have
a checklist,
but there is a certain dance that
we need to follow of special macros
to defend against and so forth.
So vector is a good one,
it's a great header.
OK, so here's vector.
Let's split this side by side.
Nope, that's not what I want.
There we go. OK, he's uh, 120 length lines
are a little bit too long for this window.
That's OK. How come I don't get
a horizontal scroll bar here?
That's quite annoying.
Uh, OK, so let's review this.
Um, first, let's make sure that the
header name is spelled properly. It is.
OK, so we begin with a comment saying
whether it's standard or internal.
The idea is that tools could pick
this up to distinguish between
standard internal headers.
I don't actually know if they ended up
doing that, but that's just our convention.
This is one of the rare cases where we
allow anything to occur before our banner.
So this is indeed an internal header.
We've got the banner for a new file,
which is good.
Uh, we've got the #pragma once.
We do not have a classic include guard.
This is not conventional.
Um, even though pragma once
does supersede the include guard
and can be used by itself,
and we do do that for like internal
test errors for all of our public
headers we define and include guard.
The theory being that we can use this
to detect when headers are included.
It seems like a good system to follow.
Interestingly, this is also
not doing the usual dance of
pushing and popping,
packing or disabling warnings,
this is purely macros.
We've got some declarations.
There is exactly 1 declaration of container,
er, __sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container.
Yeah. Alright, sorry, I, I don't know if
that if that requires pushing and popping.
Yeah, there's also a couple declarations.
OK, um, there there are a couple
of declarations of variables.
Mostly I think that we,
I think we should have the, the macros,
the macro defenses, the warning defenses.
Mostly because headers grow over time.
Today we're adding stuff for
sanitizing vector and string.
Tomorrow it will be small vector or super
string or, or who knows what they add.
And C++, you know,
37 or or whatever. Um, uh.
And if we don't have those defenses,
it would be very hard to notice
later on that they're missing.
Additionally,
we should defend against things like
non compiler tools like Qt's mock
dragging this in, unless there were
an extremely good reason not to.
I think we should have the usual
incantations, so I will add a comment here.
We should have the usual incantations for a…
a header, um, including preprocessor –
let's call them classic –
um, preprocessor guards, uh
(which we conventionally have in addition to
#pragma once). Let's see.
Uh, what else? The –
this is not an exhaustive list,
it's just a quick summary – the
_STL_COMPILER_PREPROCESSOR defense,
the packing/warning defensesm
and the `new` macroization defense.
Even if they aren't needed now,
this could be useful if code
is added/moved in the future,
and it also serves as a good precedent
for anyone
copying or imitating this header.
OK, got all my escapes there.
Start a review. OK, so #pragma once,
once we are going to imagine the
usual defenses being present, OK?
Then I don't think I need to look at
vector anymore, because that's really
just a reference for the defenses.
OK, let's look at just the code here.
So we are extracting some stuff,
but first it is guarded.
For my nemesis /clr:pure,
which we do not activate any ASan for.
Um, we, we need to ensure that
/clr:pure continues to compile,
but it does not participate
in any of our new features.
So guarding here is entirely appropriate,
if not defined _M_CEE_PURE.
That's the macro predefined macros
documented that indicates /clr:pure.
So for not pure.
And the other thing that I'm checking
for is I'm currently working
on changes to extend /clr,
the plain one, not pure to more headers.
So we're trying to avoid as much as
possible any special code for plain /clr.
And this is not caring about plain /clr,
so that is good.
So if we're not pure and grouped together,
we are not simultaneously disabling
vector and the string annotations. So if
either are enabled, we want all this stuff.
It's only if they are simultaneously
disabled that we would not want this.
This does make sense, I think so.
So what would De Morgan do? If defined pure and…
Uh, either not defined vector…
Yeah, it doesn't read better
De Morganed, it reads good.
Uh, it reads, um,
comprehensibly the way that
Nicole has written it.
OK, so for not pure and we have
not simultaneously disabled both.
Then let's define the support machinery.
I think I want to quickly check that
these are the right control macros.
I'm assuming that they are.
The old ones were _DISABLE_VECTOR_ANNOTAION, singular, and
Same for string, _DISABLE_STRING_ANNOTAION, singular.
OK, not too worried about typos there.
We do mention vector before string,
there's no real argument for sorted order.
OK, that's fine.
And the nice thing is that the rest of it
is at least consistent vector before string,
so OK.
OK, so if we're not pure and we
haven't simultaneously disabled both,
then declare cool stuff. At the end
We have matching comment #endif
not _M_CEE_PURE,
and ASan has not been disabled.
OK, that's the reasonable summary.
Uh,
we have those #endif comments so that
we don't forget which #endif pairs with,
but especially because clang-format
insists on indenting everything at 0.
Then, if defined,
double __SANITIZE_ADDRESS__,
which I believe is a compiler macro
indicating that /fsanitize=address
has been passed on the command line,
I see Nicole nodding,
so I've guessed that correctly and that's
matched with insert ASan annotations.
OK. Um, so if we are
compiling with ASan enabled,
then do stuff, otherwise do nothing.
OK.
Does it make sense to have these
as separate tests?
Yes, otherwise,
if we fuse them into a single test
that get real confusing.
It seems reasonable to have
multiple layers. So, uh, yeah,
this that is actually not the end of that
#if it's not, there's a, there's a big block #if. Oh. Right.
Yeah. I see. OK.
All of the other things. OK, then other stuff.
OK. Thanks for pointing it out.
Differently where MSVC defines _SANITIZE_ADDRESS_
playing defines, you know.
__has_feature(sanitizer) or
something like that. Ah, OK.
I see that here.
OK, yeah, line 19.
Um, and then finally there's.
Doesn't have any address,
doesn't have [unintelligible]
but we're building like an internal CPP file
and therefore we need to at least make sure
that the string annotations are correct.
OK, that makes sense.
So it's not a whole file thing.
OK, thanks for pointing that out.
OK, very useful.
OK, so it actually matches up here.
OK, good.
That is the right macro,
OK.
So if we are defining
__SANITIZE_ADDRESS__ then…
OK, these look like macros that are either:
if they're defined, they're active;
if they're not defined, they're inactive.
OK, so we're going to activate
and insert vector annotations.
Same for string.
Otherwise, OK, here's the __has_feature
that Nicole mentioned, if defined
__clang__, and defined __has_feature above
__SANITIZE_ADDRESS__ below __clang__.
This is not 100% matching the condition,
but it is OK um,
this is already pretty lengthy.
I think that's reasonable.
I won't complain about that.
Then if we can use has
feature on address sanitizer,
then define these four macros,
insert vector and activate
vector and so forth,
and then have a #pragma comment(linker, …).
And for ASan libs.
I think this __clang__ does not
imply this the way that MSVC does
because of __SANITIZE_ADDRESS__ OK.
Otherwise, OK,
I like the spacing here or the new
lines because this helps me keep
track of what's going on with all the
preprocessor stuff above __clang__ below.
If we're not __clang__ and we're
not __SANITIZE_ADDRESS__, OK,
then our fallbacks are:
if we're supposed to annotate vector,
insert the vector annotations,
but do not try to activate.
So basically, like Nicole mentioned,
mark the regions of vector that are
valid or invalid, but don't actually try to
Terminate the program or anything
if invalid accesses happen. Um.
OK, the comments here messed up.
Um, this #endif should be commented
_ANNOTATE_VECTOR.
This #endif matches with _ANNOTATE_STRING.
OK. There… the…
#endif comments here are…
Uh,
need to be fixed.
#endif comments here need to be fixed. OK.
So _ANNOTATE_INSERT…,
_ANNOTATE_INSERT_VECTOR, …VECTOR,
…STRING, …STRING. OK, so once the #endif
comments are fixed it's good.
And then #endif. The whole region began
with sanitized address OK. And then…
OK, these are also missing #endif comments.
I am going to be a stickler about the #endif
comments here just because of the
preprocessor stuff is so packed together and
it's not just like a single #if/#endif
in a stream of mostly normal code,
um, needs.
There the rationale and we are, we
are a little bit flexible these days
on admitting the #endif comments,
but I'm, I'm generally a fan of
having them because this code
is added to preprocessor stuff.
It really helps keep in track.
We've seen other code bases,
we work with other code bases where
they do not have the same #endif
discipline and it can get quite hard
to figure out “hey you know what,
what region are we in here” as I just
got confused. Needs #endif comments.
OK, so. #if
_DISABLE_VECTOR_ANNOTAION has been defined,
then #undef the _ACTIVATE… and _INSERT…
OK, so it's a full escape hatch.
Same with string.
OK here I'm just making sure that
there's no vector string swaps.
If I was extremely paranoid
or GitHub made it easier,
I would be like in VS code.
If I double click one,
it'll highlight lightly all
occurrences of the thing.
I can do that manually by searching.
This is what I do if I'm very
concerned about typos. Here the
macro name is short enough that
I can notice typos, I believe,
or like double underscores,
or anything like that,
so I think that's good.
It's a with the preprocessor
Because of something like not defined,
preprocessor statements
will happily run with that.
Typos are much more common than with
ordinary identifiers where you typo while
you're going to get a compiler error,
so you don't have to be constantly worried.
OK,
so Next up.
Now,
after determining the values or the defined…
definedness of _INSERT… and _ACTIVATE…,
we're going to admit some detect mismatches.
Mismatches.
This helps us make sure that
everything being linked into a single
binary is going to use consistent
definitions of these macros.
I'm very happy to see that
this is being used for ASan.
This is actually a feature that I
requested from the compiler back
in 2010 when we were struggling
with _ITERATOR_DEBUG_LEVEL mismatch
and it was just not diagnosed
at all by the tool set.
I asked the compiler team,
hey could we have like a #pragma?
And we invented the scheme that
was originally only for the STL
_ITERATOR_DEBUG_LEVEL but was
specified in a generic way that
it can be extended here, where if
you send a #pragma detect_mismatch
to the compiler front end,
it emits a linker directive which is
/failed_mismatch and it just works
on a pretty simple key value
system with strings.
detect_mismatch takes a key and a value.
These fail if mismatched directives
then tell the linker, “hey,
if you ever see a source file or an
object file with the directives that set
the same key to different values than
some setting is really incompatible,
you should fail the link”.
The linker doesn't actually know anything
about ASan or _ITERATOR_DEBUG_LEVEL,
it just knows about these keys and values.
So this is a sort of
generic way, extensible way for us
to ensure that inconsistent things
are not linked into a single binary.
OK, so if not defined…
Oh, and the other thing about
detect_mismatch is the linker will only
complain if it sees two of the
same keys with different values.
It will never complain if it sees
one TU you with a key value and
another TU you with nothing.
So if you want detect mismatches,
you've got to have them from the beginning.
So for example we can't detect
mixing like VS 2008 code with 2022
because that totally predated.
Of course it will fail to link for other
reasons, just not detect mismatch.
OK, so vector, vector, vector,
string, string, string. Good.
If we haven't defined _INSERT_VECTOR_ANNOTATION
then "annotate_vector" is off.
OK same for string.
OK, "0" mean off,
"0" means off and then activating.
Um.
Oh interesting.
So these are being done separately.
So if these are ever like
really set inconsistently,
we'll end up getting a detect
mismatch "0" and "1" in the same to you,
which is super horrible and
will totally [unintelligible] the link.
OK, so if you haven't turned on even
just _INSERT_VECTOR_ANNOTATION,
then you clearly want it off, if you're
actually activating the vector annotations,
meaning do the checks and
terminate the program,
If you see badness then _ANNOTATE_VECTOR
is definitely on.
And in the middle case,
if you are inserting vector annotations,
but you have not activated them,
then you don't have any detect mismatch.
I believe this is intentional.
That allows our separately
compiled libs to, [unintelligible]
[unintelligible] some on the right track.
Emits the annotations um to update ASan
about what regions the vector valid or not,
but we're not actually
performing any checking,
so it's OK to mix that with
something that will perform checking.
That seems correct and this…
and to be clear here,
the reason that we can do this
is because of the alternate name
comments below or the alternate name
Um, annotation below? I don't know what.
OK, there are linker directives I think.
Thank you directive.
Because of people.
I'm your your audio is completely
broken up and your video is frozen,
if you can still hear me.
Can can you hear me now?
I can hear you now. OK, cool.
So uh. Basically, if you
don't link with the address sanitizer
libs. Then you get the default behavior
of pulling into that thing function.
If you don't get those,
if you don't have that,
uh, if if you do, sorry,
you do link with the adverse entitlement,
then you get the actual
behavior of doing something.
I hope that made sense.
I yeah, I think that makes sense.
I think, um, there may be one case
here that we're not detecting that.
Actually, no.
Maybe it's…
Maybe it's not too bad.
Yeah, yeah, I think this is actually…
this is correct in all situations.
I was wondering what about the case
where you have one TU, translation
unit that is inserting the
annotations but not activating them,
and that's linked with another TU that
is not even inserting the annotations.
Wouldn't that lead to
inconsistent annotations?
But that's safe because the one that's
not even inserting annotations has a
detect_mismatch of "annotate_vector"
"0" and it's OK if some but not all to
use are inserting the annotations.
But we have forbidden anything from
trying to activate them because the
one that didn't bother to insert the
annotations turned on the detect_mismatch.
So and no point can you ever mix
this setting and this setting?
But if you have setting in the middle that
will link freely with one or the other,
it just can't be used to chain
them together and end you with a bad
situation where some but not all TUs
are annotating and then
somebody's trying to activate them.
So OK, this makes sense.
And I assume you're simply extracting
the existing scheme that we had
in string and vector,
but sort of just mentally double
checking it now and this makes sense.
OK, so for _ACTIVATE… we got a vector,
vector, vector, string, string, string.
That looks good. Everybody says activate.
And either one will insert a
#pragma comment(lib, …) for "stl_asan".
We use the same support lib
for either vector string.
If they're both being activated,
we'll get 2 #pragma comment(lib, …)s.
That's OK, the linker will survive.
It would be more work to try to avoid that.
We could have a separate preprocessor
preprocessor conditional that says #if
defined(_ACTIVATE_VECTOR_ANNOTATION) ||
defined(_ACTIVATE_STRING_ANNOTATION),
then have the single #pragma comment(lib, …).
But. There shouldn't be harmful to
make two of them, um.
Then the detect mismatch is are different.
OK good.
Next nice comment explain
what's going on here.
Only under _INSERT_*_ANNOTATIONS
should be used from here on.
So for the rest of the files we
will #undef …STRING… and …VECTOR….
As a nitpick,
I notice that this is
not using the same order.
This is saying string and
then vector in sorted order.
It doesn't really matter and I guess it
is the opposite of the definition order.
My brain notes that,
but it's not really harmful, OK.
And we have expanded.
That's why I put that in that order because
it was opposite, so the declaration order.
OK.
Push, push, pop, pop.
Makes sense, yeah.
OK, next we have extern "C" blocks.
We have not included anything.
We haven't even included yvals_core.h,
which the central with the which
"usual incantations" would probably
end up doing because we want at
least _STL_COMPILER_PREPROCESSOR.
We might want to use the _EXTERN_C macro here.
It always expands to extern "C".
It's not absolutely necessary.
Let me, let me check the precedent.
Um, do we use?
Plain extern "C" blocks in stl/inc.
Let's turn off this. We do.
We have a macro _EXTERN_C,
but we do not consistently use it.
Um, we've plenty of uses
of plain extern "C". OK.
That the existence of that macro,
I believe dates back to when yvals_core.h
could actually survive as a C header,
which we no longer support.
I do wonder whether we should come at
the close here of that externality block.
Usually I feel that we do.
If it's big. I don't know if we
have a lot of examples of big ones,
it's not actually that big here.
That's about the upper limit of what I would,
uh, find reasonable.
Yeah, everything else is so
small it doesn't get a comment,
and if playing format doesn't add one,
it's fine.
These `#endif`s are at least I
know I'm not picking these.
Are there at least only controlling one line
and they're separated from everything else?
I don't feel that they
absolutely need comments.
OK, so if _INSERT_VECTOR_ANNOTATION,
we have an external const bool
_Asan_vector_should_annotate
similarly for string and string.
That's good.
Here are mentally checking do
we need anything for modules?
We do not because it's extern "C".
And I'm sure that was capturing
the original code as well.
Um, OK,
Next up we do have a combined #ifdef
check if either defined(
_INSERT_VECTOR_ANNOTATION) or
defined(_INSERT_STRING_ANNOTATION),
then have all this common support machinery.
OK. And this is the #endif.
I believe that's paired with that
#ifdef _INSERT_VECTOR_ANNOTATION
OK, so then we're gonna have an
extern "C" declaration of a function.
OK, so going through my mental list.
Um.
It's not template, it's not static,
not inline, explicits procedures only,
it's not virtual.
We return void, so no reason for like
[[nodiscard]]. Always needs a
calling convention
_cdecl
__sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container
has some names of parameters,
first, end, old_last, new_last,
all ugly,
all ugly.
It is not marked noexcept.
But we might need to survive, OK?
It's not marked, noexcept in the
address sanitizer header and so,
if you included both the standard
header and the actual sanitizer header,
you would get no accept mismatches. Ah, OK.
OK. And eternity will, at least under /EHc,
assume that it will not throw exceptions,
so that seems reasonable.
OK, and then a dense forest of #pragmas.
This is, I'm assuming,
just extracting what we already had.
Um. This is the sort of stuff
that is needed for to work,
so I'm not too worried about typos here.
I'm just going to check the
architecture conditions.
We have so many architectures, it's fun.
#if defined(_M_ARM64EC) [EC – emulation compatible],
then they've got these real special
mangled names #elif defined(_M_HYBRID)
for the chippy older architecture. OK.
#elif defined(_M_IX86) for x86 otherwise
for the NORMALISH architectures …X64,
…ARM, …ARM64.
OK, so we have to intercept …ARM64EC,
and …HYBRID before anything else
because these are overlapping otherwise.
The classic ones …X86/…X64/…ARM/…ARM64,
these are all mutually exclusive
so the order here doesn't matter,
and this is reasonable,
we do this elsewhere. And then if
none of those have been activated,
well, you're compiling on, you know,
something from the far future,
so we say “unknown architecture”.
OK, that seems reasonable. OK.
Yep, uh, the …X64 and so forth mangling
does not add anything,
and we just say use the defaults.
…X86 adds an extra under score for extern "C"
…HYBRID adds some of these pound signs.
OK, that'll looks good.
OK,
and our validation ensures that
the header ends with a new line.
OK, this looks like a good header.
OK, now let's look at um,
maybe <vector> first before we
get to the actual <string> stuff.
This is essentially should be
I recommend <xmemory> first. OK,
first because it has a very large comment.
That's exactly what's going on,
and our annotations for vector
were wrong in very specific
weird cases. Ohh, interesting.
OK, well let's review that then.
Thank you. Um.
OK, <xmemory>, which is one of
our centralish internal headers.
Although not the most central,
this is one is included by,
like, all of the containers. We have a struct.
This camel case naming is not quite
conventional for us, but it's OK-ish.
Umm. Though that's new,
we didn't used to have that.
Uh, we should probably follow the convention.
Yeah, I'll comment on that because
if we want to change it later, um,
it would be possible to change,
but we should have followed the convention now.
OK, let's see.
We conventionally use _Ugly_snake_case for
types and functions in the STL
_UglyCamelCase is used for
template parameters like _RanIt.
It's a good example of an internal type.
I think the vector values the one
that comes to mind. Like _Vector_val.
OK. Naming. We conventionally
use _Ugly_snake_case for types and
functions in the STL (like _Vector_val).
_UglyCamelCase used for template
parameters (like _RanIt). OK,
so we've got a struct _AsanAlignedPointers.
It's internal so I'm mentally
checking against modules.
No modules impact.
That's good that none of this PR
should be affecting public names,
so we shouldn't expect to
see any changes to export.
It has a couple `const void*`s,
_First and _End.
They are not initialized anything,
so this is an aggregate,
there's no constructors.
How do we use this?
Do we use it in this header or no?
It looks like we use that elsewhere.
Let me look at some uses so I
get an idea of how it's used.
There's a very big explaining comment.
Uh, there's one use.
Oh, there's a function that returns it.
_Get_asan_aligned_first_end in <xmemory&gt.
OK,
returns it with braces.
OK. It seems fine this in aggregate.
I don't see a need for nonstatic data member
initializers because we never use them.
If we said initialize them to nullptr,
that would just be dead code.
It wouldn't be wrong,
but there's no strong motivation,
it's internal only.
If this was intended for wider use,
I think it might be nice to have [unintelligible],
but mixing like non null
and null would be bad too.
So sort of better to just
not have anything there. OK,
then we have a helper function or a function.
Um, this is a pure observer?
So it should definitely be no discard.
It is constexpr returns a construed star.
It's called _Clamp_to_end.
Takes const void* _Mid.
It's constant snow, except that looks good.
We have an _STL_ASSERT that
activates only in debug mode.
That the _Mid being passed in must
be greater than equal to _First. Um.
Why is there an empty string here?
Does that _STL_ASSERT even take a…?
Yeah, it takes a string.
We should have a message here.
Yeah.
At least a minimal one. Yeah,
it's a debug function or. Sorry,
no, it's an internal function like,
Does it really need it?
Um, they actually,
the question that comes to mind is,
we usually use _STL_ASSERT and its uh
companion still verify when user
submitted arguments could violate
preconditions of the standard.
If it's something that we expect
users to never activate
through their own misadventures,
but would only happen if the
library code is logic errors,
then we usually use an STL internal assert
which is only active for our code base.
We I know we have one for stack::
insert we have just killed.
Yeah, I thought we had one
that was always STL internal.
It looks like _STL_INTERNAL_CHECK is
the name um for the runtime, yeah? Yeah.
It's like STL_INTERNAL…-something-other.
We got a lot of uses of it. Um.
Yeah, I think that's what this should be.
No, hold on. What is? What's going on here?
Ohh we use _ENABLE_STL_INTERNAL_CHECK to activate
The _STL_INTERNAL_STATIC_ASSERT
but where do we use it?
Oh yvals.h uses it to activate
OK becomes an _STL_VERIFY.
OK, so external check will always
run this, but only in the test harness.
There's no reason for _STL_ASSERT.
OK, I will add a comment
saying that that's what we want and that
one I believe, does not take a message.
It does not take a message, OK. Um.
If this is checking for logic errors in the
library implementation (such that user code
passing, say, or can't. Er… such that
user code violating preconditions.
No let's not get into that.
Umm. This is checking for logic
errors in the library implementation,
we should use _STL_INTERNAL_CHECK
which doesn't take a message.
OK. This is checking for logic
errors in library implementation,
we should use _STL_INTERNAL_CHECK
(which doesn't take a message).
Umm, excuse me. OK.
And then this is doing the clamping.
If the provided _Mid pointer is strictly
greater than our stored end pointer,
then clamp to _End.
Otherwise it is less than or equal to _End.
And. We are…
We've already asserted that it's got
to be at least _First, maybe bigger,
so we can just return _Mid.
OK. That seems reasonable.
OK, so now the big comment. Um, here we go.
Uh, the way that ASan shadow memory works.
Each eight byte block of memory shadow
memory section has a single byte to
mark it as either poison or valid.
Each section has zero to 8 valid
bytes followed by poison bytes, so.
And then here's some examples
for how many bytes there are.
Three valid, followed by 5 poison.
Or. 8 valid are OK,
but poisons followed by valid
is not OK that makes sense.
This function,
which is being defined way below,
exists to fix up first and end pointers
so that one can call
__sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container and
__sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container
checks that `first` is
aligned to an 8 byte boundary if
`end` is not aligned to an 8 byte.
__sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container
still poisons the
remaining bytes in the shadow memory section.
OK, so we're going to check that the
first one snaps to 8 bytes and if `end`
is jagged.
If it doesn't align to an 8 byte boundary,
we're still at least going to
poison the remaining bytes, OK.
Because of the second property,
we can only mark poison up to the final
aligned address before the true last.
OK, otherwise we'd poison the
memory after last as well,
and that doesn't belong to us.
OK.
OK,
I think I understand what's going on here.
For the first property we can assume
that everything before `first` in the
shadow memory section is valid,
since otherwise we couldn't mark
first valid and so we just return
back the first address in `first`.
Shadow memory section OK,
and I very much like that every
mention of `first` in its meaning of
parameter is escaped by backtick,
so we can use the plain word
first without confusion.
OK, so here's an example.
cpp code.
Uh, you've got a struct
with alignment of eight cat,
which has an int meow
spanning bytes 0 through 4.
OK,
non inclusive we have a char buffer
[16] with no alignment requirement
and that extends through bytes
4U through 20 not inclusive and
then an int purr occupying the end
bytes 20 through 24 not inclusive.
OK that looks good.
It is aligned as 8; 24 is divisible by 8.
OK, as an aside,
we have an undocumented compiler
option /d1reportSingleClassLayout
which is quite useful to view this.
I'm going to take a little detour
and show this on Compiler Explorer.
Can't remember if I've mentioned
it before in code reviews,
but this is ever necessary.
Uh, let's use MSVC. We want um.
Compiler output. OK, so x64 MSVC, latest.
OK, so if we compile with
/d1reportSingleClassLayout and
then this takes a substring of
the classes you want to look at.
This one is cat,
so I'm going to say lowercase cat here.
It prints out an ASCII art diagram here.
It's picked up a couple of other things like.
atl::implements_categoryAttribute,
which is like predefined or something,
but here we get class cat.
It's a 24 byte class and it begins.
It offsets 04 and 20 from your buffer and
per just like Nicole's comments demonstrate,
and no padding.
So if you're ever confused or
uncertain about the layout of a class,
try using D1 report single class
layout and then name of class.
It's undocumented and unsupported,
but we've supported well,
we've implemented it for many years and
it's probably not going away anytime soon.
OK, so first meow and purr are
just regular data members,
not container buffers, so they must be valid.
OK, then assume we want to
poison all of buffer.
This would mean that in a perfect world,
we want something like…
OK, here's a very nice diagram.
Um, with
bars showing where bytes begin and end,
and the bars begin on these spaces.
Very nice.
OK, so meow is all valid the buffer?
OK, these SMs are the shadow memory
segments because ASan thinks about
things in eight byte granularity.
OK, so the entire buffer is poisoned.
OK,
and then however note that by the
rules above sm3 the shadow memory is
not a valid shadow memory section.
We always need the valid bytes
to come before the poison bytes.
Thus,
the closest we can actually get to it
is… I see the cat noises have attracted well,
Hi Kitty.
Now we can mark all of SM3s valid.
OK,
so we're sort of losing out on some checking,
but this is unavoidable where
dereferencing near the end of the
buffer has to be accepted because
it's so close to the valid memory purr.
This example is extremely enlightening!
Thank you for writing this up!
This was obviously a ton of effort to draft,
but the pictures demonstrate the
complicated concepts here are
much better than the words can.
OK, very useful.
Incredible amount of trial and error
that went into figuring this out by the way.
No, not documented unfortunately.
Yeah, and yeah, the result is oh,
just crashes with some horrible,
you know,
inexplicable reason rather than
a nice compiler or anything so.
OK,
so we call aligned equals get
aligned first end with cat buffer,
cat buffer plus 16 and we get back aligned
with members first is address of cat.meow.
OK, that's a plain pointer,
not any sort of pointer to data member,
and the end is the cat.buffer plus 12,
which is here.
OK. Um.
Then we poison as much of
buffer as we can via
__sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container(
aligned._First, aligned._End,
OK, uh, can.buffer here, and then
aligned._Clamp_to_end(
cat.buffer + 16))
OK.
So the… OK that… that finds this boundary.
Here we are allowed to assume that
address can't meow is valid since
otherwise cat.buffer plus anywhere
between zero and four could not be valid.
We cannot poison up to cat.buffer
+ 16 since then the address
of &purr what could not be valid.
Thus, this results in the shadow memory
state from the second example. OK.
And? That would be this example here.
Yeah, because this is clearly not
the first and second example.
OK, this comment makes sense. Thank you.
OK, so now we've got plain inline function,
so it is _NODISCARD because it's
only returning stuff.
It's got to be inline because
it's not a template.
We return an _AsanAlignedPointer struct,
_Get_asan_aligned_first_end.
Because it returns a _First and an _End.
Those are the names of the members.
We take _First which is a constant
pointer to constant void.
Same with _Last.
It's noexcept OK,
We have a…
constexpr uintptr_t; `static` here
is not necessary but not wrong,
so that's fine.
static constexpt uintptr_t
_Mask is take the _Asan_granularity.
Which is a power 2 minus 1,
flip the bits so it turns off all the bits.
For the power of two, OK,
and that's why we can mask it.
We reinterpret _First and _Last to
uintptr_t, apply the mask,
and then go back to const void*.
OK, that's great.
Amy, who is the tech lead on Asan,
says: “for the _Last pointer,
I think this goes back to the beginning
of the current longest of advancing to
the beginning of the next chunk?” “Correct.
We can't advance the beginning of next
chunk; see the example in the comment”.
OK, so we're only ever
stepping things back,
because of the nature of the mask.
OK, good,
that's going to result in nice codegen.
Then we have a couple of variable templates.
This code goes down to C++14,
so we need the _INLINE_VAR macro.
We are…
partially specializing,
but not explicitly specializing.
So that's good.
We've got this headache where if we ever
explicitly specialize a variable template,
that's actually bogus without
actual inline variables,
but partial specializations are OK.
So template<class _Container,
class = void>,
because we're going to do void_t.
_INLINE_VAR constexpr size_t
_Container_allocation_minimum_alignment is…
so by default we get the alignof
the element type, the typename
_Container::value_type OK,
but if something is valid.
If we can form a [unintelligible] void_t,
the decltype of the _Container::allocator_type::
minimum_allocation_alignment.
So if you have…,
if the allocator has this value,
this thing does not need typename anywhere,
because we eventually end a new value.
Then we call
std::max,
and here we're in <xmemory>,
so we have that available wrapped in
parentheses to defend against macros.
Um, and what are we taking the maximum of?
Either the thing that we would usually use,
alignof(typename _Container::value_type).
But if that's tiny,
like if it's just a char or something,
then we're guaranteed that the allocator
will at least be returning stuff aligned to
80 or 16 byte or whatever boundary it says.
But if the element type has
a huge alignment requirement,
well,
of course then that is the alignment
requirement we're going to use.
So, maximum is correct.
OK, that looks good.
That's all the changes to <xmemory>.
OK.
See. So now we've got changes to
<string> and <vector> and then the test.
OK, let's see. Got a little bit time.
Let me go through <vector>.
OK, so we're now going to include the
support header with angle brackets.
Uh, we're going to do that.
Within the compiler processor guard,
but it's not conditional on language
mode and it's outside our push pack.
This is the right location.
OK, so then we're lifting out all this,
uh, duplicated slash unified code.
Yep, so this is activating the stuff,
the #pragma comment(lib …),
the declarations, the alternate names.
This is great. This was detecting
the minimum allocation alignment.
We've just reviewed this.
Um, this has been generalized too.
Previously it took a vector and
asked what its value type is.
And now the stuff that's in the <xmemory> um,
works with arbitrary containers,
not specifically _Vec,
and it's doing std::max. This is…
This is returning a bool:
“Do you have a minimum allocation alignment?”
The other one just returned what the
minimum allocation alignment was.
OK. And then the detect_mismatch.
OK, _Get_aligned_first
This is being removed.
Looks like some of the masking work is
being moved to that helper function,
so we're going to see something that.
Replaces this, but it's not just a
code extraction. OK, so here we go.
So that tight there was wrong.
Basically,
If you have a pointer pointing at first.
Uh. This is like up in memory towards
end and this is back in the [unintelligible]
It would push the pointer forward.
So that you couldn't poison like, let's say,
the first four bytes of the buffer.
But it turns out. That's not true.
We can't just push the pointer backwards,
because we know that this must be valid in
order for this to ever possibly be valid,
and so we can't actually poison
the 1st 4 bytes of the buffer.
OK. Through the masking.
Uh, first and I think is what it's called.
Uh does that? That's the correct masking,
so this is the OK.
And. Pretty complex.
OK, so this is actually a correctness fix.
OK, that's good. OK, so goodbye,
_Get_aligned_first.
Um, now we are _Unfancy'ing pointers
because we support fancy pointers,
which are things that we obtained
from an allocator that look like
pointers but are actually user
defined classes or something.
So whenever you see _Unfancy or _Refancy,
that's what we're dealing with.
So we are taking…
Are we doing here… applying annotation which
works with fancy pointers in a vector.
We have to _Unfancy them all to
raw pointers, they're just losing
their trailing underscores.
They're all double const.
OK, and then uh, extra parentheses here
to make clang format do the right thing.
If constexpr the _container_allocation_minimum alignment for our vector is
strictly greater than _Asan_granularity then…
We can call __sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container
without adjustments.
Otherwise we need to adjust. OK and here.
Ohh greater than or equal. OK.
Looks like this comment doesn't mention
that, so I will add that. Let's see.
As you mentioned that this
should be a greater equal check.
OK, great. Thank you.
I didn't. I actually wasn't.
Even though I'm a fan of uh checking
for uh strict versus um except equal,
I didn't think to question it there,
so I'm glad you did.
So if the allocation minimum
alignment is greater than or
equal to _Asan_granularity,
then this adjustment is not necessary.
OK, um, there's some comment here about.
Possibly removing an optimization
because it's making things more complex.
I'll let you decide whether that's necessary.
OK, so the old state, not an optimization.
That's when you know about the allocator.
We can push it forward.
We can push the. Could have back.
So this is actually fixed in my
local branch and I apparently forgot
to push before I left for home.
So OK. Sorry. OK, let's uh,
let's see if I'm catching this correctly.
OK, how does this sound?
And Nicole mentioned that this
is needed for correctness and
is not purely an optimization.
OK. Okay, oll state include _First
exclude _Old_last is valid,
and then from _Old_last
excluding _End is poison.
New state _First to _New_last
is valid and then _New_last…
And… so there simply _Old_last was the
boundary between valid and poison.
We're moving that to wherever
_New_last is so _CSTD qualify,
which just means global scope
__sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container(
_First, _End, _Old_last, _New_last) OK.
Otherwise, so, call the new thing
um const auto _Aligned is _STD
_Get_asan_aligned_first_end
give it _First and _End.
If the struct that we're given says
if _Aligned._First is equal to _Aligned._End,
well then there's nothing
the buffer does not end…
The buffer does not end at least one
shadow memory section. Nothing to do.
Am I misparsing this? What is end mean here?
Does it mean contain? No.
Basically, in order to mark part of
a shadow of every section as poison,
we need to know that we own the final
byte in that shadow memory section.
OK, so for like you're purely
within a shadow memory section,
you don't contain the end of one of them.
OK, so that's what this means.
OK, so yeah, so we can actually be
in the middle to another middle,
and we can poison at least
like the 1st 4 bytes. Right.
Yeah. But you can't be purely
within a shadow memory.
OK. I think that makes sense
that the charger for my phone.
OK, um, then early return.
_Old_fixed and _New_fixed,
_Clamp_to_end _Old_last and _New_last.
OK, so now some comments of the
old state and new state and these
are all inclusive-exclusive.
They're all properly uglified, OK.
Ah, that makes sense.
_Old_fixed,
_Old_fixed and _Aligned._End
were the old boundaries and now
_New_fixed and _Aligned._End. OK.
So we're just moving _Old_fixed
to _New_fixed, OK.
Call __sanitizer_annotate_contiguous_container
OK, more discussion here.
Clamped end handling the concern.
OK. It looks like this is resolved.
That's good.
OK, that's all the changes to <vector>!
OK, I think I've worked at my
confidence and I can now review <string>.
OK. <string> includes the
support header not guarded by
compiler version or standard version.
OK, that's in the right place.
We are extracting out the string
annotations and we are now activating them,
so we'll need to go resolve this bug,
which is great. OK.
Extract out the allocation stuff, OK.
Now #ifdef _INSERT_STRING_ANNOTATION,
we have a helper function.
We look like we're within.
A class here indeed we are within
within basic string itself.
Yeah, this looks like basic string itself.
OK, um, so and are we in?
We're in the private section.
OK, #ifdef because this is a defined
or not macro _INSERT_STRING_ANNOTATION,
then we're going to have
a helper function here.
This is a function so we can get the
alignment of the class while defining it.
Because of the fun fact that a
class is only complete within
its member function definitions.
If you're simply looking at like
variables, like static data members,
then it's not actually complete yet.
It would be circularity if you try to
check the alignment and size of the class.
So it actually has to be a function.
So that makes sense.
Um, that's subtle enough that it
is worth a comment. I like that.
So we have _NODISCARD because
it's a pure observer.
This is a static contexpr
bool _Small_string_always_asan_aligned.
Can't be const because you're static.
It's no except OK,
so the small string is always ASan aligned.
When a bunch of conditions are true,
the align of ourselves, basic_string
must be strictly…
Sorry, must be greater than or equal to _Asan_granularity.
So this check is good.
And the _Memcpy_val_offset modulo
the _Asan_granularity must be zero.
OK, so our boundaries at the right place. And…
Uh, let's see…
This whole condition must be true,
the sizeof.
value_type of _BUF_SIZE.
Oh, this is an array.
I was like index into a value type. No.
This is the size of an array of, um,
buff size elements of value type. OK.
Which I guess could have been expressed
as sizeof(value_type) * _BUF_SIZE
because we don't expect any padding.
But that seems reasonable.
So the size of essentially our
small string buffer modulo _Asan_granularity.
Must be 0, so you've got to be evenly
divisible. Um. Or if it's not um?
Then. If they align of this size_type…
The align of our size_type…
Ohh this is looking at the x86 or x64.
Basically the reason for all of this
is because I am trying to check one
whether it's always aligned to the
like the beginning of the buffer
is always aligned on the boundary.
That's true. The first two things are true.
The second thing is checking
if size doesn't get put in the shadow
memory section of the buffer.
So having in between
If the buffer and a shadow memory buffer,
that's fine. Or if padding like
pads the size, type out to the…
the next shadow memory buffer
shadow memory section, that's fine.
Yeah, this is a. This is a lot.
It is kind of terrible,
but that that's basically the idea.
Is is so that you don't poison size_type,
You're my size accidentally.
OK, Umm, I'm going to add a comment here.
Um. If it would be possible to
add additional comments, um,
explaining what you just explained,
that would be helpful,
because there are a lot of conditions
here and the intention of them is
less than completely obvious.
So comments explaining what
is the meaning of this,
the meaning of each sub-condition
here would be very helpful.
OK, great.
OK, so now _Modify_annotation
is changing signature.
Uh, _CONSTEXPR20 cause string and vector
have to be constexpr in C++20 mode.
But now instead of just taking account,
we take a const size_type _Old_size, const
size_type _new_size, const noexcept.
OK, Umm, this no longer just says “Extends/
shrinks the annotator range by count”.
You have it.
You have to explicitly tell it what we're…
what was the old size and the new size.
That's nice. That avoids confusion.
If they were the same, “hey,
nothing to do, return”.
Otherwise they're different.
We gotta do stuff. So _Apply_annotation(
_My_data._Myptr(), _My_data._Myres,
_Old_size, _New_size).
OK, simple as can be.
Um, and then.
We now have a new function.
_CONSTEXPR20 static void _Remove_sso_annotation
(const _Scary_val&
_My_data) noexcept. OK.
This thing is um,
I think we mentioned another code reviews,
but uh,
basic_string and vector and all the other
containers have base classes to help
limit the impact of their allocator.
So allocator,
iterator or iterators for containers
only depend on important attributes of
the container,
and not on different allocator types.
Um,
so, removes annotation of this small string
optimization buffer with shadow memory.
This results in the ability to copy
into the SSO buffer without worrying.
OK #if _HAS_CXX20 / #endif _HAS_CXX20,
OK, so if we are constant evaluated,
which we do with our runtime check runtime,
then return.
Because we're not going to do
any ASan stuff, of course.
ib, um, constexpr land.
OK.
Um.
Otherwise we're either not 20 mode so we
don't have to worry about constexpr string,
or um,
we are in 20 but we've
determined where at runtime.
OK, so we can proceed.
So we have a couple const void*
const _My_buf = _My_data._Bx._Buf;
_End = … _Buf + _BUF_SIZE, ok?
Repeating them has no cost
and aligning them nicely,
so that's fine. if constexpr(
_Small_string_always_asan_aligned()).
Then nice before after comments,
old state,
new state from _My_buf to _End is
unknown and now _My_buf to _End is valid.
_My_buf _End _My_buf _End OK.
Otherwise const auto _Aligned =
_Get_asan_aligned_first_end.
OK.
The old state we had valid some unknown
stuff in the middle and then valid again,
and now everything's going
to be valid because…
What's going on here?
We are removing the SSO annotation.
The small string isn't always ASan aligned,
so we want to just remove
that annotation to say: “hey,
everybody's valid”,
OK.
OK, looks good.
Another function _CONSTEXPR20
static void _Annotate_switch_to_large,
(_Scary_val& _My_data)
noexcept. annotates exactly the pointers
as valid because we're switching to large mode.
And we're going to be storing
a pointer in that union.
Again, if we're in CXX20 mode,
if we're constant evaluated then return.
Remove any SSO annotation.
And then capture _My_buf, _Ptr_last is…
OK, this is a repeating.
Oh no, this is not repeating.
This says _My_buf is _Bx._Buf
_Ptr_last is _Bx._Ptr + 1.
And then _End is using _My_buf + _BUF_SIZE.
Uh, that's… that's correct.
Um, I'm wondering if it makes sense
to group _My_buf/_End just so
that puts the buffs together and
then the _Ptr one is separate.
It's probably not strictly necessary.
OK, _My_buf comes before,
_Ptr_last comes before _End
OK. The locations?
Ah, OK.
And this is doing pointer arithmetic.
It's not plus one byte,
it's plus one pointer worth, OK.
if constexpr _Small_string_always_asan_aligned,
then the old state _My_buf to _End
is valid from _Remove_sso_annotation
which we just called, new state from
_My_buf to _Ptr_last is valid,
but from _Ptr_last to _End is poison.
OK, otherwise const auto
_Aligned = _Get_asan_aligned_first_end get AC line for send.
The old state again.
_Aligned._First, which we just got here and,
is valid for _Remove_sso_annotation,
and then we're going to
mark the middle as poison.
OK, because we are switching to large,
so the buffer in general is poison. Um.
OK, but the pointer, of course is fine.
OK.
_Alinged._First, _Alinged._End, _Alinged._End, _Ptr_last.
Yeah.
[unintelligible]. Kind of think um.
This is an extra pointer.
Does this make sense?
I'm worrying about exactly where this
boundary is because I'm wondering,
is there a distinction between
arithmetic in the byte domain and
arithmetic in the pointer domain um.
I think I may need A to look at.
Whoops, where's string itself?
I want to go to <xstring&>.
OK, so we've got a _Buf, I think _Bx.
No, we don't say union that often.
OK, there's one occurence union here we go,
um, so we've got
the array of _BUF_SIZE `value_type`s.
For a narrow string,
this is 16 narrow carriers.
Followed by a pointer.
And then followed by this alias thing that,
um, it's a union of all these things,
and this one we can basically ignore.
So it's a union of them both.
Interesting. And then we've got the
_Mysize and Myres after that, OK.
So want to split this.
Here and here OK. OK, so we've got.
_My_buf is the beginning of the string.
Because that the _Bxty union is the first
element um _Ptr_last is the address of.
The _Ptr which is also the
beginning of the string.
Plus one so. OK, so _Ptr_last
points to the byte
immediately after the pointer.
So if a pointer is 8 bytes, this will
the pointer exists in the 1st 8 bytes,
0 through 7 index and then blah plus
one is pointing to the 8th byte,
the byte at index 8, the 9th Byte actually.
OK. So and then _End is
_Bx._Buf + _BUF_SIZE which is
the end of _Bxty or an end of _Bx
OK. OK, so _Ptr_last does indeed
point right beyond the _Ptr.
It doesn't point at the end
of the second pointer,
and there is no second pointer point set.
The end of that reach.
OK, so _Ptr_last.
That is the right name for it too,
because it's exclusive. OK, so.
Did this make I think I'm
convincing myself this is correct.
New state _Aligned._First, up to _Ptr_last
is valid but excluding it.
OK, so this is saying.
The order is valid.
Everything from _Ptr_last
to _Aligned._End is poison.
So the part of the union that
we're not using is poison.
OK,
this is correct.
I was worried that we're like
consuming 2 pointers worth,
but we're only consuming one.
That's all good.
I mentally create the diagram in my head.
OK, we're now done with
_Annotate_switch_to_large. _Apply_annotation.
Parameter used to be called _Ptr,
now it's called _First and
gains top level const.
Uh. This code goes away.
We have new code here.
This is not helping things GitHub.
I want to switch to side by side.
What I really want is the thing that
we have in our internal reveal tool,
where I can switch entirely to new
code but see only what's changed.
Rather than just looking at the file
as a whole, I dislike split mode,
but I'll use it if I need to.
OK, too far down, here we go.
We just finished _Annotate_switch_to_large.
OK, _Apply_annotation comes first.
OK, so old code goes away. Now we have:
Note that capacity, _Old_size and _New_size
do not include the null terminator.
So const void* const
_End = _First + _Capacity + 1; OK.
_Old_last = _First + _Old_size + 1;
These are… what are these `value_type`s?
Why are they plus one? Oh,
because of the the null terminator.
The null terminator is a factor for the size.
So I could imagine that,
but why would we be doing
this for capacity here?
Because our capacity is.
Our actual capacity minus one.
Ah, OK, that's why I forgot.
[unintelligible] Done. Yeah, yeah.
It's an old representation
choice before my time, so. OK.
Thanks for mentioning that.
OK, so that's all correct. Yeah.
So whenever I see a null terminator,
I'm like: “whoa, sirens, you know,
something could be wrong here”, um.
constexpr bool
_Large_string_asan_always_aligned
Oh yeah, and you
um, so n-u-l is the ASCII name
for the null character.
But if you spell it out as a word,
it's reasonable spelled out like
this thing that would be wrong.
Would be all capital and all,
because that's the macro for
the null pointer constant.
Null terminator like this I think,
is conventional.
I don't think that's wrong.
I… I… I guess you could have, um,
different stylistic convention,
I suppose.
Um, the the one I'm allergic
to is referring to a null
terminator is all capital,
which it's not.
OK, uh, _Large_string_asan_always_aligned.
It's constexpr bool when the
_Container_allocation_minimum_alignment
for our basic_string is greater
than or equal to _Asan_granularity.
OK, if constexpr _Large_string_asan_always_aligned
and _Small_string_always_asan_aligned, then “hey,
the stars have aligned!” old state: _First
valid ends at _Old_last and
then the rest is poison.
We're moving that to _New_last.
OK, good. _First and _Old_last
_New_last, otherwise, OK,
this is just getting indented.
Why is this not?
No, it's not getting it.
It's getting significantly changed.
It's just not doing interline differing.
OK, otherwise const auto _Aligned
is _STD _Get_asan_aligned_first_end.
the buffer must always have
size greater than or equal to 9 bytes,
so we'll always end at least
one shadow memory section.
OK, so you have that guarantee
that we talked about. Last must be
less than or equal to than end.
So fix up when _Aligned._End
is strictly less than
_*_Last OK um.
_Old_fixed _Clamp_to_end,
_Old_last, _New_fixed _Clamp_to_end,
_New_last, OK. Old state.
Here these are actually contiguous lines,
just the narrow screen is messing things up.
The valid boundary was an _Old_fixed
_Aligned._End poison, new state.
These old state / new states are very
nice to explain what the intention is.
Um. OK, that's good.
Now we have some helper macros.
Everything after this is a lot easier
and once all the support machinery
is defined and I think we can
actually go back to intra diffing.
Reload.
OK, scroll, scroll, scroll.
OK, the macro helper macros.
No more _ASAN_STRING_MODIFY
in taking one arg.
Now we take 3 args, _Str, _Old_size, _New_size.
Calls (_Str)._Modify_annotation
(_Old_size, _New_size)
We now have other macro …_SWITCH_TO_LARGE
Which will take our _Scary_val base
class call _Annotate_switch_to_large,
or _Remove_sso_annotation, OK.
These match the names that seems reasonable.
Otherwise expands to nothing.
We still have remove and create,
but none of this modify
or the single arg modify.
OK.
So
Um.
Is this merge damage?
This looks like… this is a change that
Casey recently made, I thought.
Yeah, that must be merge damage.
OK, I'll add a comment.
I think a merge was incorrectly
resolved here. Um, I also,
I'm not sure if you've merged with main.
Um. Please double check that you have
merged with main and picked up…
Let's annotate for the records
what PR we're talking about.
This was like a whole seven days ago,
so I've completely forgotten.
That's not actually useful.
Let me look at <xstring>
My memory is sort of timeless.
I'm like, oh, we changed something there.
And it could be, you know, 12 years ago,
it could be seven days ago,
and I'll remember it the same,
but I don't remember exactly what changed.
OK, So what is the history?
I was Casey's miscellaneous cleanups.
We… we created PRs almost simultaneously.
Mine was various cleanups.
His was miscellaneous cleanups and
finding some good stuff to clean up,
but small enough that it didn't
make sense to accept for PRs.
Yeah, so here Casey said: “OK,
we're going to take _Al, we're
going to use to construct the
allocator in our compressed pair,
but then we don't need to redundantly
provide it to _Move_construct_from_substr”.
That one can just use our allocator.
We have a whole function for that,
so this function doesn't take out at all.
So if you've merged with main,
there should not be showing up as an edit.
Um, yeah, something's gone wrong.
Interesting with the merge there.
As an aside, I can.
Uh, use this opportunity to mention a
tool which I really like and I think
I've mentioned another code reviews.
I know you're aware, but for our audience.
If you're looking at our repo,
or any repo if you've got git installed,
you can use gitk and that will launch…
Let me drag it over here…
A graphical viewer of history,
and this lets you to see what
branch you're on, um,
what commits you're looking at.
Our main branch always has
completely linear history,
but it's possible to see merges and stuff.
And there's other ways to get this info.
There's other graphical viewers.
You can do this on the command
line with some graph arguments,
but I like gitk and it can be helpful to
understand what you've merged recently.
OK.
So we want to pick up 3178,
um.
OK. Double check that sorry citation it is.
OK, straight damage.
Um, let's see what's going on here.
So we're moving the assignment
of count down, that's fine.
And then _ASAN_STRING_CREATE
with this. OK.
I don't know if it's necessary
to move the _Mysize down.
Was there a rationale for
moving this assignment?
So everywhere else. Because.
I think everywhere else we have
_Myres assigned first _Count,
assigned second or _Mysize assigned
second string create third.
Ah, so that that's what that the idea was,
then. OK, big fan of following um,
uh conventions within a single file,
so thanks.
And then we're moving up the
_ASAN_STRING_CREATE before we start
actually assigning to the stuff.
That seems entirely reasonable.
OK. Um, here. What are we doing?
Are we still within the same function?
Nope. We're in _Construct_from_iter.
So _ASAN_STRING_REMOVE(*this),
remove any special annotations.
Switch to large.
Miscco, who worked extensively on string,
says: “something's fishy here.
At the end of the function,
we call _ASAN_STRING_CREATE…”
Nicole reply switch to large
creates a validation region inside
the SSO buffer for the pointer
because we're switching large mode,
and then _ASAN_STRING_CREATE creates a
valid ASan region in the large buffer.
OK.
Yeah,
trying to communicate complicated concepts
and like 3 and one words is difficult but,
and this seems reasonable.
Um.
I wonder,
I wonder if comments like
we've generally moved away from
redundant comments and functions,
but maybe explaining this in the
actual functions would be useful.
Did we have that? Umm.
Where? Where are they?
This is a plain annotation.
Switch to large annotates
exactly the pointer is valid.
OK, that summarizes what you said.
Then what was the other one create?
We'll just create call macro.
Sorry for scrolling.
Because the existing create annotation,
OK, I think,
I think we've already got comments there.
So this doesn't demand an extra comment.
OK.
And then changing the arguments
because modify is no longer
taking a delta of size.
You take the _Left_size, _New_size,
or you pass the _Left_size and _New_size.
OK, let's make sure all
these are actually correct.
Interesting that _Right_size
was a asked as a delta before,
it's always because we're concatenating.
Yeah, we're concatenating. OK, got it.
I was also checking to see if some
variables had become no longer necessary,
but of course we're going to
still need the _Right_size. Um. OK.
So we are concatenating it
_Fits_in_left take _Left's buffer.
So old was left, new was new size.
If. And here I'm assuming we're
fitting _Fits_in_right.
Yeah, _Fits_in_right.
You have allocators equal in _Fits_in_right.
Then we're starting with _Right_size
and becoming _New_size.
And I need to go so OK,
thanks for the review.
Awesome. Thank you, Nicole.
And I should probably um finish up
uh myself because we are at 5:26.
It looks like the rest of the changes
here to string are pretty minimal.
So I will go ahead and submit
partial comments. I'll come back
and our review the test code later,
but I'll capture these comments here.
This is looking very solid.
So thank you for working on this
extremely difficult problem and enabling.
String ASan annotations which
will be a great feature.
Bye, Nicole,
and thank you for watching another
VC libraries Open code review.
We'll see you next time.